quand vous souvenez vous connaissez sans
doute l'action de madame marthe richard
qui en 1946 avait obtenu la fermeture de
ce qu'on appelle les maisons une mesure
qui à l'époque avait pour but la
protection de la femme et la lutte
contre une forme établi de proxénétisme
presque 30 ans plus tard madame marthe
richard vient de se déclarer favorable à
l'ouverture d'une chaîne des roses
center c'est à dire de deux maisons de
tolérance d'un style plus moderne
inspirée de ce qui se pratique paraît-il
en allemagne en scandinavie qui plus est
marthe richard vient d'expliquer au
micro de france inter que la loi qui
porte son nom lui semble maintenant
dépassé elle a même voulu rencontrer
l'animatrice d'un mouvement qui milite
pour le retour à ce genre de loisirs
organise dans toutes les discussions
relatives à la prostitution
on confond généralement la question
sanitaire avec la question policière je
lutte d'abord pour la question sanitaire
ça c'est un point qui en somme un grand
d'apporter ans en france et maintenant
les maisons je demande qu'on leur ouvre
des maisons je suis d'accord avec madame
et je suis persuadé que là il y aura
aussi docteur et tout ce qu'il faut pour
donner des soins à l'occasion puisqu'on
ne peut pas empêcher la prostitution
elle existe depuis tout le temps
alors puisqu'il y en faut mais ton pour
le moins le moindre mal et ça c'est le
moindre mal mieux que de les bars les
femmes aux portes des hôtels dans les
rues
voilà pourquoi il faut modifier
certaines lois et voilà pourquoi je vous
ai contactés
et oui vous les avez fermé à moi de les
faire rêver mais c'est pas facile à moi
je préconise que des maisons soient
construites mais pas une maison seul nom
de petites maisons dans un gros bang
oui où elles vont uniquement travailler
voilà en somme vous êtes en train de
monter un syndicat des dames de petite
version pâte syndicales et syndicats
sont toujours but politique une
association à but non lucratif parce que
je vous dis une corporation sont les
groupes et ensemble on a plus de plus de
pourquoi deux points wii que si on est
isolé chacune de son côté à se tirer
dans les pattes et un pain savoir
comment faire on a aussi nos petits
problèmes à discuter ne serait ce par
exemple que s'il faut augmenter le tarif
selon le coût de la vie pourquoi vous
prostituées vous - très bien parce que
c'était le seul moyen que j'avais de
gagner de l'argent de subvenir aux frais
d'éducation monfils et puis de vivre de
vivre indépendante de tout le monde les
femmes en france quand elles sont celles
de famille et qu'elles doivent se
débrouiller avec puissant 903 paroisse
vous pouvez toujours courir avec des
enfants encore c'est une vocation une
vocation petit
faut-il vous dis la vérité faut-il vous
dire que toutes ces filles ont horreur
de cela pour ne pas reculer devant le
mot que sale et dégoûtant plus qu'elle
se tape des crises de nerfs le jour le
soir quand elles travaillent là qu'il
faut parfois les consoles et qu'elles
sont souvent attaqués en plus malmenés
et qui par les étrangers encore et
parfois même par des français moyens
le français qui se dit bien élevé mais
pour cet